yeah of course you know I think the
question is given but India is going to
be super why just given us because it
has a fundamental some fundamentals are
very vital to lose the political
establishment the political system the
democracy the ability for people to
innovate grow prosper and they are
sufficiently empowered to be
entrepreneurial and creative of value
and contribution with the economy the
question is when what can we do to
really make it as fast as possible and
to have systems and processes in place
for it to be more inclusive sooner
rather than much later I think that
would be the key thing we all should
work towards in Ian James and the
formulating policies and the
government's working on empowerment to
have more contributors from our just
some sections of the society towards
that goal of becoming India becoming a
superpower but more importantly for
everybody to take part in that process
as soon as possible Thanks